(upbeat music)
- Good morning, I'm Dr. Kyle Pruett
of the Yale Child Study Center,
also a member of the Early
Childhood Peace Consortium.
And we are inviting you
to the second discussion
in the ECPC Raising
Children of Peace series.
This is a natural topic for us to take on,
we are in our 10th year.
We have been growing and
developing as an organization,
and it has become very
clear to us that the need
for the the youthful voice is essential
to our being able to spread
the very important message
about the importance of
peace in early childhood.
The generation represented
on this panel has taught us
a great deal about this concept,
nothing about me without me.
This is an organization of young people
and a generation of young
people who have given
a great deal of thought to how their voice
needs to be respected
because of the things
that they have to say about
the way that the world
is affecting them very directly.
And this discussion is
about this intergenerational
conversation which is
essential to enlarging
our understanding about
the importance of peace
in the early years.
The group that you see in the
gallery will be introduced
by Kyle King, who is a
rising senior at Yale.
His invitation to his
colleagues has been essential
to making this conversation even possible.
You will hear from each of them.
He will introduce each of them in turn,
we will then be joined by Aditi Shrikhande
of UNICEF at the
end for a conversation
and round table roundup of ideas.
And then we will finish
this morning's conversation
with thoughts about the future.
Kyle King, thank you, the floor is yours.
- Thanks, Kyle.
Hello everybody, my name is Kyle King.
As Kyle Pruett said, I'm
a rising senior at Yale,
and I myself have been
doing advocacy work for
about eight years now, primarily
with two organizations,
the International OCD
Foundation and UNICEF.
And before I go ahead and
introduce everyone else
on this panel, I wanted
to take a minute to share
my own experiences with advocacy,
and hopefully say something
interesting as I talk about
my work with those two organizations.
I started with the
International OCD Foundation
or the IOCDF when I was 13,
right after I finished
treatment for my own OCD.
I was diagnosed with that when I was 12,
and after a pretty
grueling year of treatment,
I thought if I could do
anything to help someone else
with that disorder, I would do that.
So I reached out to the IOCDF,
I asked if I could be an
advocate and they said sure.
But then they gave me
no further instruction
on how to do that.
My journey with UNICEF
started two years after
when I was in 9th grade.
I was walking up a staircase
at the back of my high school
and I saw a poster of a boy
who is standing in the rubble
of what was his school.
And here I was standing in
my well-funded public school
in South Florida,
and there he was standing
in the remains of his.
And I just was struck
with this thought that,
really there's no difference
between him and I,
I just happened to be born here
and he happened to be born there.
And it felt so unfair to me
that because of some
arbitrary cosmic coin flip
I had access to all of these
resources and he didn't.
So I felt like I needed
to do something about that
and I went and joined
my UNICEF club that day.
And I've been doing work
with both those organizations
for like eight years, like I said.
And I've gotten to see
firsthand how they interact
with youth advocates and they've
done it really differently.
And I think there's something
to be said and learned from
the differences that these
two organizations show.
So starting with the IOCDF
since I started there first,
when I reached out when I was
13 as I kind of alluded to,
they provided me very little support
and very little guidance.
And they didn't really tell
me what I could or couldn't do
as an advocate.
They just said sure,
you can be an advocate.
And I don't know if you
remember when you were 13,
but I wasn't a terribly
confident 13 year old,
I didn't want to talk to adults very much.
So for the first couple years
I really didn't do too much
with the IOCDF because
I didn't really know how
to use my voice.
My experience with UNICEF
was really different.
When I was 15 and wanted to join
and start working with UNICEF,
I just went and joined the
club in my high school.
And that was a really
easy way to get started.
And had there not been a
club at my high school,
UNICEF has full webpages
dedicated to helping kids
start a club in the United States.
And even beyond the clubs program,
UNICEF USA has positions baked into
their corporate structure
for youth advocates.
So that's kinda the long
way of saying that UNICEF
does what the IOCDF didn't,
which made it really easy for me to begin
my advocacy journey with them.
And as a result, for
the first couple years
of my advocacy work, I
mainly worked with UNICEF.
And as I kind of worked my way through
the different advocacy
positions at UNICEF,
I began to build up my voice
and I began to become a lot
more confident as an advocate.
And consequently, I
began to have more ideas
and really want to implement
them more strongly.
And that's when I began to
realize that the structure
that UNICEF had laid out for
me and that the IOCDF hadn't
was a bit of a double-edged sword.
Because over the years there's
been a lot of times at UNICEF
where the structure began
to feel a bit confining,
and I began to feel boxed in
and I felt like I couldn't
really use my voice
as authentically as I wanted to.
So looking back at the
IOCDF that experience
was totally different.
Because after I had kind of
found my voice at UNICEF,
the lack of structure and
the laws of fair governance
over there began to
feel like a huge asset.
I could do the projects
that I wanted to do
as authentically as I wanted to do them
and I would try certain things
and sometimes they would fail
and sometimes they would
be great successes.
But it was really
incentivizing that I was able
to do the advocacy work that
I really truly wanted to do.
And I don't mean to disparage
either organization,
they both meant a lot to
me as I've been growing up.
And they both taught me a lot
of really important things.
But one thing that I wanted to communicate
to all of you as you look to engage youth
in whatever organization
you're representing here,
it's necessary to meet
youth where they're at.
Because before a young
person finds their voice
and when they are getting
started in advocacy,
it's really daunting, it's
a really scary experience.
And it's really important to
have those easy to get into
positions like UNICEF did
to help them along their way
and help them find that voice.
But once they find that voice,
it's really important to
genuinely and earnestly
hear that voice out and
allow a young person
to express their voice less
they might lose it entirely.
Okay, that's a lot from me.
The two Kyles have spoken too much.
It's time to pass it on to
the other youth advocates
on the call.
Just by way of context, we all met,
me and the other three young
youth advocates at an event
that was hosted by UNICEF
last September in New York.
We didn't know each other
prior to getting to New York
and then we met in New York and we spent
three days together.
And in those three days we
grew so close that I could,
oh, I don't know,
ask them to participate
on a webinar on a whim,
which I think is pretty
cool that we became
such good friends so quickly.
And I think it's because we
all have a lot in common.
So without further ado,
the first youth advocate
who would be speaking today
is Penelope Lea.
Penelope is a climate justice advocate
primarily from Norway.
And she's one of the most
accomplished advocates
I've ever had the pleasure
of meeting in my life.
And she's also one of the
sweetest people in the world
and I think you'll learn a lot from her.
So Penelope, your time to shine.
- Thank you so much Kyle
and thank you for your talk.
Thank you for having me.
I started my activism when I was eight.
I started because I was and
I still am sick and tired
of violence and inequalities.
And the fight for climate justice,
the fight for climate
action is the fight against
these very forces.
Before I started my activism,
I experienced violence in close relations.
And this experience
actually became my entry
into climate activism.
It fueled my need to speak
up and it strengthened
my impatience in the fight for a peaceful
and safe future for
everything I love, the people,
the nature and life itself.
And this impatience of mine
has only grown since then.
As we know, climate and nature changes
are an amplifier of all
other crisis we face
as humans beings.
The climate and nature
crisis is inevitably linked
to the world's security situation,
to economics and poverty.
It's tightly linked to how
we understand ourselves
and our own history, and
of course to every single
one of the human and children's rights.
I believe to understand
it another way is naive.
Therefore, as a climate justice activist,
I've found myself working
with several of these issues
over the past 10 years.
And in this talk I wanna
share some of my experiences
with you.
But first, I would love
to mention some background
on the conversation
around climate and nature
in my home country,
to give you in a better idea of how it is
to be a climate activist here.
I believe I can safely say
that the debate around climate
and nature changes is the
most polarized and heated
that there is in Norway.
Norway is a small country
with five and a half million people.
In 1969, we found oil and gas.
And since then we have
built our whole economy
on oil and gas production and export.
Just before the summer holiday,
19 new oil licenses were
approved by our government.
And there is currently no political party
that stands a chance
of forming a government
that wants to stop giving
out new oil licenses
and move away from fossil
fuel dependency fast enough.
In 33 years, our government has only cut
our greenhouse gas emissions by 4.7%.
We are one of the countries in Europe
with the most climate deniers.
One in four people in Norway don't believe
that climate change is
caused by human actions.
There is no excuse for
Norway to delay change.
We have the solutions, the
resources, the possibilities,
the peace, and the people
in power have had the time.
We keep on living with
and enjoying the freedoms
people before us have fought for,
democracies, weekends,
eight hour work days,
they did it for us.
And still we seem to think
that it is impossible
to change the systems we live in.
To me, that is double standard.
We can change what we view
as political impossible.
But to be able to create a
better world and to make people
aware that it is in
fact possible to change,
it's been proven that we need
the voices of young people
and we need to ease the
struggles young people face
in their advocacy for basic human rights.
So now I'm gonna share
some struggles with you,
me and my friends face in our work.
We often talk about how
young people need to speak
truth to power, but we rarely
talk about what happens
when power speaks to you,
the hate you might receive.
Lots of activists live in
places where it's not safe
to speak your mind or
be politically engaged.
And even the ones of
us that live in safety
can be unsafe at some point.
We need to hear the
voices of these activists,
we need to hear the voices of activists
from the frontline communities.
We desperately need that representation,
but we have to make sure
that these spaces are safe
for young people to be represented in,
not just at the stage but
afterwards, you need to follow up
and make sure to the
best of your abilities
that they have the support
and safety that they need.
One of the ways to do
this I believe is to build
more political organizations
for young children, community.
When I was younger it felt life important
to be able to use my voice and get heard.
For me it was a question
of all or nothing.
I needed to use my voice and feel like
I had the say in my own
life and my own future.
I needed to contribute.
But when you're young
it's often very difficult
to find organizations
where you can do just that.
Where you're not just
questioned because of your age
but brought up and valued
where everyone understands
that your thoughts are
your own and filled with
as much integrity as if you were older.
I started my activism in
an organization like this,
but we need help building more of them.
Youth organization and frontline
communities needs funding.
The money is not going where it's needed.
It's in the hands of huge
companies and businesses
serving exploitive systems,
gaining the very few,
but not with young change makers
or the frontline communities
fighting for a better world.
And we need to change the conversation
around funding as well.
Too often my friends and I
are met with huge skepticism
when we advocate for climate finance
or funding of youth advocacy communities.
But one needs some level
of financial security
to be able to work for other freedoms.
At the UN General Assembly,
Priyanka, Dominique, Kyle and I,
repeatedly heard the statement,
if you don't have a chair at
the table, bring your own.
That is not possible.
If you're not invited and
you don't have the resources,
it's of course not possible
to grab your own chair
at the table.
And it's not just about
having a chair at the table,
but having a role at the table,
getting opportunities to speak, talk,
follow negotiations
actively, ask questions.
We need to talk about the conversation,
the connection between human
rights and children's rights,
peace, security, and climate change.
And a lot of young people
in the climate movement
want to talk about these connections
because it's crucial to understand
to be able to implement the just solutions
and have the just transition we need.
But it is of course viewpoints seldom,
it's hard to get through in media.
So we need help from every one of you
to bring this conversation
forward so we can move forward
in the fight for climate justice.
I believe activism is
in its greatest form,
peace building in its nature.
We might never know which of
our actions may lead to change
or may make more people
follow in our footsteps.
Therefore, everything we do
may turn out to be important.
When I hear myself speak now,
I realize that a lot of points I have
have to do with building
safety for young people
in one way or another.
I believe to be able to
build peace in any form
you need safety, peace
is in my experience,
not always peaceful,
but you need safety to
be able to fight for it.
Thank you.
- Thank you Penelope, that was incredible.
And when you mentioned that phrase like,
if there's no seat at the
table or bring your own chair,
I remember hearing that
phrase so often that it became
somewhat hollow because like
you said, in my experience,
it's not always as simple
as just bringing a chair.
And a lot of times there
are people at the table
who don't want to hear
from a young person,
even if you get there in the first place.
Our next speaker is Dominique Ogreanu,
which I hope I pronounce correctly.
And she's a young advocate from Romania.
When Kyle asked me what advocates
I'd wanna have on this panel,
I immediately thought of Dominique
because I've met a lot of
advocates through the years
and I don't know if I've met
anyone else whose emotion
and raw passion for the
subjects that they advocate on
is as evident as it is
when Dominique speaks.
They are really special
and I'm really excited for this talk.
- Hi, thank you so much Kyle.
Oh, that was such a nice
introduction I wasn't expecting,
definitely no pressure on
me to deliver that emotion.
So I'm very grateful to
be here with all of you.
I'm so grateful for Penelope
for sharing her experience before me
'cause a lot of the things
that she has touched upon also
they'll find themselves
throughout my talk as well.
So when I was first invited here
the first question that
popped into my head was,
what is peace?
Because we hear this word everywhere
and it's on TV all the time,
we hear it at high level
dialogues at school.
So in preparation for the
talk and for my speech,
I ask the children that I work with,
how do they define the concept,
what is peace for them?
And I observed that as
their age got higher,
their responses were
more complicated, right?
They were sprinkling this
according to this academic paper
or it's actually hard to define.
And less of their answers
came from their souls
and too many from the external forces
that they have interacted with.
So one very interesting
definition that I heard
and it was from from one of
my colleagues that is 10,
was that peace is the
possibility to play without fear.
And it was very important
because many children
trade their childhoods to fight
because the problems are so pressing.
So fear, fear is one of
the worst motivators,
but it is one that brings
children to advocacy,
be it fear of not being accepted
to fear of being killed.
And upon hearing the word fear,
I immediately thought about resilience.
How many times did we as youth advocates
hear that we are resilient?
How many times did you
as an adult hear it?
And resilience has become
code word for silence.
You are so resilient because
you can take injustice
so easily, you absorb it
and you don't make a sound.
You don't express the the grief
you feel, the worthlessness,
the exhaustion because you can take it.
And this upholds the
idea of individuality.
Like you are the
responsible for your mood.
And it is through this
that we allow each other
to rid of the collective duty
of protecting one another.
It is this that becomes an obstacle
to intergenerational
communication to peace.
Because peace means
taking care of each other.
Now, to understand how youth advocates,
how to help youth advocates,
you must understand their journey.
And while what I'm about to to talk about
might not be a universal account
since everybody has a unique way,
it is based on my experience
and on those of the people
that I truly love.
I truly believe that
there are three feelings
that you encounter at all
times in your activist path.
One is rage, the other is
loneliness coupled with belonging
which I name as the
feeling of in betweenness,
and then there's hope.
These coexist at any
time during your path,
they don't alchemize
from one into the other,
they uplift each other, they
spring from one another.
So let's start with rage.
I often felt that my
country was at war with me.
That it's hatefulness
for dissenting bodies
pierce through my soul and
it extracted all the light
and the love I was
desperately trying to harbor.
So determined to banish me from contesting
their hegemonic practices.
Different systems like
nationalism, capitalism,
heteronormativity, invaded
the minds of others,
my teachers, my colleagues, my friends,
isolating me from those
I was fighting for.
And it is not easy to care for a community
that seeks to destroy your will and agency
and to convince you of your worthlessness
because these oppressive systems
seeping through the minds
of those we love show up as
Penelope said, as immutable.
They are power impossible to
contest without a movement.
So with this in mind in the
universe of museum arrangements,
architects sat down, created
a city at the intersection
of the public and the private
and asked the vital question,
what if we put together people
broken by the same systems
and just let them love each other?
So in a room with a circular
table on the third floor
of a building in the city of Foley,
a group of students from
different parts of the world
and their professor met
every day to discuss theory
as a way of survival.
All having been hated by
their countries at a point
in their lives or aching for
connection and understanding,
they explored the musings
of those in history
who share their struggles,
unintentionally creating good
transgenerational knowledge hub.
This is how you build a movement.
You bring the outcast, the
thinkers, the believers,
the reformers, the revolutionaries,
those who want to rebuild the
systems that are hurting them
and you make them a safe haven.
And in this place of
safety you let them revolt,
you conspire with them, you
make plans, you organize,
you let them discover their identity.
I remember the immense
rightful rage that I felt
when in my freshman year of
high school my colleagues,
my LGBTQ colleagues came
to me and told me that
we can't keep each other from dying
as they were building
their own networks of care
in absence of support from our teachers.
Because what else can you feel
when your planet is on fire,
or when you get denied
lifesaving procedures,
or when you're outed and marginalized,
what are you supposed to feel if not rage?
We encounter unfairness at
different times in our life.
But the first feeling is that
we are alone in this hurt.
That we are the first to experience this.
This is where intergenerational
support comes in.
Visibility is everything.
As you discover people who think like you
and who for decades have been
involved in the same activism.
Activism is a love story.
Beyond the anger, there
is a group, a movement,
a collective to which you
belong and with which you fight.
And in the darkest of
nights when you're defeated,
it is the people that become your fuel,
the solidarity and support
you are overcome with.
When you are in tears and
at the brink of giving up,
you look up to them and they
reassure you that they fought
through worse times and
that you have the tools
and the foundation to fight
whatever your enemy is.
But above all, you have the
promise of no matter what,
no matter what happens,
intergenerational support has your back.
In these spaces of safety you
learn to choose joy over doom.
You are free to play,
you construct the safe haven of peace,
this manmade circle of unity.
And then you take it
outside to the real world.
Soon enough you become
a safe space for others.
The peace inside of
yourself reflects outwards.
While you constantly wonder
what really is the impact
you're making, your
caretaker will sit you down
and tell you, I don't
understand this issue
you're advocating for yet
but I'm willing to learn.
Your friend will ask you to
go to a protest together.
Your teacher will sign your petition.
The youth you encounter will
ask you how to get involved.
You'll become a catalyzer,
a unifier, an antidote.
All we really want as youth is
to be safe, to be understood,
to see our loved ones and
caretakers enjoy safety as well.
Now for this to happen, adults
need to decenter themselves
to come into our communities,
to bring the power table that we've been
talking about before into our communities
and let us work together
instead of against each other.
While safety continues to be
seen in securitization terms
like countries, borders, national spirit,
we must remember that these
are abstract concepts,
but people are real, feelings are real.
When we try to define peace,
perhaps we should ask
ourselves how peace feels
rather than what it means.
So I want to leave you with
a question before I end,
how does peace feel to you?
And I'll start, for me
peace feels like relief.
It feels like taking a breath
after holding it for so long
because finally in the
dark room that you thought
you were in and that my
country was desperately
trying to put me in at the
beginning of the story,
there suddenly are people's
hands to hold, light garlands
and a lot of hope.
That was it, back to you, Kyle.
- Yeah, Dominique, you more than lived up
to the introduction I gave you.
I'm reflecting on the question,
what does peace feel like?
That's a complicated question to answer.
I think I would say like ease in a way
I am thinking of my own
experiences being marginalized
for having a mental disorder
and walking into a place
and not being marginalized for
that feels like ease to me.
But I'd have to think about it further.
Our third youth advocate
is Priyanka Lalla.
She's an advocate from
Trinidad and Tobago.
And just a cool part of her biography
that I wanted to highlight
before she speaks is that
she is an author and an
illustrator of a book called
"Svara's Ocean Adventure"
that she published in 2022.
And I feel like it's a little
unfair that someone has like
that much talent like they
can draw and they can write.
I don't know, it just kind of made me mad.
But Priyanka, the floor is yours.
- Thank you so much.
Good morning everyone, and
thank you for having me.
Kyle's story resonates with
me because when I was about
six years old when I saw a
young boy about eight years old
selling vegetables with his parents,
I told my grandfather that
I wanted to be his friend.
I felt that if we knew each other,
he would live my same life.
And growing up in a small
island he has allowed me
to have a close look
at the world around me.
It's given me an incredibly unique
and invaluable appreciation
for nature and therefore
a passion to protect it.
The beauty of my island was
mine to explore and cherish.
And this is truly where my advocacy began.
In 2017, at the age of 10,
I came to the realization
that this narrative of
protecting and preserving
the environment was not
practiced by most of our region.
Evidence of dumping was
discovered in the mountains
of debris and pollution washed up after
the devastating hurricanes Irma and Maria.
I felt compelled to take action.
And I knew that if I wanted to see change,
I could not go around
asking others to change.
I needed to start on my own
and I needed to lead by example
to mitigate the risks of my country
and region's peace and security.
My advocacy began with education.
I believe that our school
curriculums did not sufficiently
address climate and environmental issues.
And certainly there was little focus
on meaningful sustainability.
Our economy similar to Penelope,
is based on oil and gas.
And we have little
attempts at diversification
to ensure a regenerative economy.
Young people need more
opportunities to thrive
and this has led to brain
drain over the years.
This is a threat to our country's peace.
I decided that I would be
the change I wanted to see
to build a more sustainable country
and a more sustainable region.
And this inspired my
blog, Zero Waste Living.
I learned a great deal
from my grandparents
who lived sustainably because they learned
from their parents and that influenced
the way in which my family already lived.
I guess we can say this is an example
of intergenerational education
that was happening in my home.
And this quest for sustainability
led to the creation
of the Zero Waste Lunchbox,
an initiative that I started at my school.
I encouraged students to pack a lunch
with no disposables or plastic.
And my dream was that
one day this would become
a Caribbean wide initiative.
I simultaneously created
a Zero Waste blog.
I researched and wrote
about how we can make
almost every aspect of our
lives more sustainable.
And I realized that
meaningful climate action
was not difficult for my small island.
We did not need to reinvent the wheel
because the solutions already existed.
As just a few decades ago our grandparents
were living sustainably.
When I became a national
child rights ambassador,
I found a connection
between climate change
and every aspect of child
rights and human rights.
But what stood out to me the most was that
along with child rights
came responsibilities.
We have the right to a healthy and safe
and thriving environment,
but it is our responsibility
to maintain and ensure that
for ourselves and for future generations.
And after around four years
of consistent advocacy,
young people started
to contact me asking me
what gave me the courage to do this
or how they could get involved.
And it became so clear to me
that there was an audience
of young people out there,
but they lack the opportunities
and the support they needed
to realize their true potential.
And one of my successes was
becoming a UNICEF youth advocate
where I was able to meet
young, enthusiastic people like
Kyle, Penelope and Dominique,
who truly are passionate
about their cause.
And working with UNICEF and
its partners has helped me
to learn more about the climate crisis
and how every aspect of our
lives is affected by it.
I would say that one of
my biggest accomplishments
is my participation in
the regional consultation
for Latin America and the Caribbean
on drafting the general
observation number 26,
on children's rights and the environment
with a special focus on climate change.
And after this conference,
my eight year old sisters Vara
and I wrote and illustrated
and published as Svara's Ocean Adventures.
Our objective was truly climate education,
engaging, empowering, and
inspiring climate education,
giving children the solutions
that they could implement
even at such a young age.
But I still believe that
we have an uphill battle
in small island developing states.
We are still faced with the
issues of general disconnect
between real climate action
and what is being taught
in schools and local programs.
Climate and environmental issues
are taught in science class
without any reference to
how we are contributors
on a daily basis.
Many young people continue
to use single use plastics
and are often encouraged
to start beach cleanups.
However, they do not realize
that they are contributing
to the problems.
What is required is not cleaning up.
Every time but a reduction,
but in short term and
ultimately a ban of these items
and environmental laws to be enforced.
It is our peril if this is ignored,
our vulnerability is always
evident when we are hit
by natural disasters.
Entire communities are destroyed
causing children to be taken out of school
to support their families.
And when they are taken
out of the education system
they are forced into child
labor, child marriages.
And due to less income,
they are usually left with poor nutrition
and no way out of this cycle.
Our rising crime rate, food
insecurity, increasing figures
in non-communicable
diseases and urgent need
for transformative education
are some of the factors
that jeopardize regional peace.
People fail to make these connections
between the reality and the climate crisis
which we feel and see the
implications of every day.
We cannot have sustainable
development and peace
under these circumstances.
And while I have seen a
growing number of young people
joining the conversation or
taking action in small ways,
it is not enough.
In a country with 1.4 million people,
the numbers in the
conversation are very small,
a few hundred maybe.
I also question the quality of involvement
as sometimes young people
invited as what appears
to be tokenism for photo ops
on preparation of reports
for funding agencies
and plans for meaningful
long-term engagement
seem to be theoretical.
I truly believe in
intergenerational action
where we must work
collectively and in harmony
to create affordable,
accessible, and sustainable
education systems with
capacity building opportunities
and programs for young
people to truly be engaged
and to know that they have
a right to have meaningful
seat at the table but there's always hope.
Thank you.
- That was also just an incredible speech.
I was just reflecting again
on the seat at the table
and the issue of tokenization
that you brought up
'cause I felt that multiple
times through my advocacy.
Just feeling like I was
invited to an event,
someone took a picture of
me and that picture ended up
on a PDF online somewhere.
But I didn't really get to
say anything at the event
other than just cheese.
Kyle Pruett, the floor is yours.
- Thank you, Kyle.
I'm writing down pearls as fast as I can.
I feel very privileged to be sitting here
with this remarkable
group of young people.
I'm struck by their
passion, their impatience,
the problems at the table that
they so accurately highlight.
This conversation is I hope
an antidote to that problem
at the table.
The hope that I believe
Dominique spoke about
reminded me I believe Bill McKibben,
the very active climate activist,
talked about hope as a verb
with its sleeves rolled up.
And each of you have talked
about action, passion,
your competence is very obvious
and we are looking forward to hearing
not only more from you,
but we're now going to
have the treat of listening
to Aditi Shrikhande,
who is the early childhood
development program officer
from UNICEF.
And Aditi has the delightful
task of summarizing
some of the things that she has learned.
I hope she is as perturbed as
I am by the wonderful things
that you have brought to
our table today, Aditi.
- Thank you, Kyle.
Yes, I do wanna echo exactly
what you've just said.
This has been so fascinating
and I really appreciated
learning from each of the
experiences that you've shared.
So big thank you to all
of our presenters today.
And I think some of the
things that you spoke about
really caught onto a lot of the key themes
that at UNICEF as well
we try to incorporate
into peace building things
like community leadership
and community engagement,
mental health and wellbeing,
and empowering young people to be leaders
and supporting their
organizations and initiatives.
I think these were all things
that I heard from all of you.
And at the heart of UNICEF's
peace building work,
this is what we strive to do as well,
to take a child centered
social services approach
and to bridge community and
intergenerational divides
to reduce social tension and address
the root causes of conflict
which I think some of you also mentioned.
So there was a lot of alignment
there and I appreciated
hearing that from a less
theoretical jargon filled way
and more applicable to
people who are living
their lives every day.
So it was great to have that framing.
I said a life course approach
is what UNICEF takes.
And again, I think this
is something that I heard
from many of you particularly Priyanka,
I noted that you mentioned solutions
for age appropriate
solutions that children
could take to participate.
And I really like that
you brought up that point.
So as Kyle Pruett mentioned,
my background is in early
childhood development.
And we believe that peace starts early.
Right from birth children are interacting
with the world around them
and they are developing
critical skills, emotional regulation,
empathy, social skills.
And there are two really
key moments for building
these cognitive and socialization skills.
And one of those is early childhood,
so which would be roughly
the ages of zero to eight.
And the other is in adolescence,
which is I think we heard
many of our presenters today
started their journeys around that time
which is incredible.
So these periods of time
particularly in early childhood,
is when children are learning
attitudes and behaviors
towards the other.
And in resource poor contexts,
the access to services that promote
early childhood development can also act
as social equalizers.
So they can help with
breaking cycles of inequities
and injustice, making
individuals and societies
more resilient to stress.
Dominique, I noted your point on the use
of the word resilience and I
love that you brought that up.
So when I say resilience now,
I mean a communal societal resilience
rather than an individual, let's
pretend everything is okay.
And I really appreciated
that you unpacked that.
So UNICEF has recently
come out with a new vision
for early childhood development
which explicitly recognizes
the symbiotic relationship
between peace building
and fulfilling children's rights,
particularly their right to development.
And of course, this applies
to working with young people
as well.
UNICEF's mandate goes up to 18,
but of course we recognize
the fundamental role that
anywhere people from adolescence
to young people, whatever,
that category looks different according to
whichever theoretical
framework you're looking at.
But essentially, we know the
activists were speaking about.
And there is an underlying
trust in the fact that
youth play a really catalytic
role in building peace.
And therefore the work
that UNICEF tries to do
is to teach peace building
and resolution skills,
conflict resolution skills.
To support those youth-led initiatives
that we've heard about
today at a community level
and at wider levels as well,
and to really strengthen
the participation,
the meaningful participation
of young people
in national dialogues and decision making
and peace building processes.
I think it's a fairly
common complaint really
that tokenism sort of takes over
rather than actual
meaningful participation.
So I do believe that
that's one of the things
that UNICEF is trying to work on as well
and I appreciate it that our
presenters spoke more to that.
I think what I found really motivating
about what all of you spoke about today
was the way that you
reframed these topics.
I think very often topics
particularly those associated
with young people tend
to be depoliticized.
And I appreciated that you reframed that,
you politicized it and you made that
clear connection to piece.
Actually I think there was a particular,
yes, sorry, Penelope you
mentioned you never know
which actions lead to peace.
And I think that that is
something that becomes very true
particularly in defining peace, right?
This is again, a topic that was spoken to.
So we've had things like climate change
are slowly but surely becoming political,
but not necessarily things
like sustainable initiatives
like those that you've told us about
Priyanka that you've started,
or mental health or community,
I believe there was a phrase
Dominique used the networks of care.
And all of these being highlighted
as efforts and acts of peace building
is what I truly appreciated
that all of the presenters
brought to the floor today.
- Aditi, could I interrupt
for just a second,
and as you were talking
about networks of care,
I wanna remind people that their questions
are welcome in the chat.
We will be monitoring
those and after Aditi
has completed her comments,
we will address the
questions that you would like
addressed not only to the
presenters but to Aditi as well.
Speaking of networks of care,
you are all a part of it.
Thank you very much, go ahead.
Sorry to interrupt.
- No, no worries.
It was actually great timing.
I was just about to move
into the discussion portion.
So I noted from many of
you that you mentioned
the lack of meaningful participation,
or the opportunities
for that participation.
And I think something that
we've seen through research
is that young people
research and of course
hearing from experiences,
young people often create
their own spaces for expression
and building community and
leadership and for example,
using digital platforms, online advocacy.
And I am just wondering
have any of you encountered
the need to find your own
space in the same way?
And if so, what did that
look like in your experience?
And over to anyone who would
like to respond to that?
- I can go first maybe,
I think that is what activism is about.
And you mean I constantly
search for new ways,
new peaceful and democratic
devices I can use
in order to contribute to
the changes we need to see.
And a lot of these things
are spaces we make ourselves,
and try as a future
movement internationally
and nationally in my home country
is a great example of this I believe.
And millions of young people
going out into the streets
building our own platforms
and strengthening
each other in our work.
And so that is just one
example of like many things,
many times we've build our own communities
and build our own places.
Yeah, I think that's the
core of being an activist.
- Thank you, Penelope.
Did any of our other presenters
want to speak to this?
- I'd just like to add
on to what Penelope said,
in my personal experience,
one of my first initiatives
was my Zero Waste blog.
And I started blogging because it's a tool
that I learned how to use
in school and I felt that
social media and the digital space
is where our generation is,
it's where we spend most of our time.
And it was how I could
engage with my peers
and other young people in the Caribbean.
And I started blogging about Zero Waste
not only to engage with young people,
but also their parents and their guardians
and being able to create
something more personal
and unique to our circumstances.
How can we implement
these sustainable habits
into our households,
our school curriculums,
our communities, to make it
a Caribbean wide initiative
and something that's easy
and affordable to implement.
And social media and my Zero Waste blog
was the perfect avenue to
achieve this because of its reach
and its connectivity.
- Thank you, Priyanka.
And I want to appreciate
as well that you said
the reach of the blog but
you also were an active part
of creating that reach and I think
that needs to be acknowledged.
Kyle or Dominique, did you
want to come in as well?
- Yeah, sure.
Because I feel like especially locally,
physical safe space was always
created by the community.
Children and youth advocates have created
their own additional
spaces inside their schools
if they never felt safe
there or outside of schools.
And adding on to what Priyanka
said about the digital space,
I think that the digital
space has brought a component
of trans nationality to youth
advocates organizing, right?
You find somebody in a different country
that has the same problems as you,
and together you create
this transnational space
of solidarity.
And from there, you of course
have lovely initiatives
like the one we are
participating in today, right?
Because Kyle reached out to us digitally
and now we're all here from
different parts of the world.
So yeah, I think that
constructing your own space
as an activist is like Penelope said,
one of the core components of advocacy.
- I also like have experience
I guess making my own spaces.
I started like support
groups for young people
or community groups for
young people with OCD
and stuff like that.
But the challenge is
like remaining in silos
of just young people doesn't
get the job done all the time.
And it's important to have
conversations like these
where we interact across
generations and with people
who are in I guess, higher
up positions to make
more systems level change.
And also you mentioned tokenization
at the very beginning of this question.
And one point about
kind of like tokenizing
or having youth kind of at events
and maybe not knowing if you're engaging
in tokenization or not,
I've felt tokenized at
different events within UNICEF
or the International OCD Foundation.
And when that's happened,
I felt angry at times.
But even though I was tokenized,
it felt nice to be there
and it gave me a lot of
confidence being in those spaces.
And even if maybe people
didn't respect me that time
or didn't like listen to
what I said that time,
being there made me feel
like my voice mattered
a little more than it did before.
And then the next time I
was there I was able to talk
a little louder and maybe
they didn't hear me that time,
but then the next time I
was able to a little louder.
So I guess if someone is
scared that they might
be engaging in tokenization,
invite youth anyway
because in my experience
it has only helped me
get a little bit closer
to being heard.
- Thank you, Kyle.
And I appreciated the practical
solution there as well.
That's a great way to think about it.
I would love to be able to
open this up to the Q&A.
At the moment I don't see
anything in the Q&A box,
but if anyone in the
audience has a question
for our presenters, please
do add it in to there.
And while we're waiting
for those to come in,
I'm just going to monopolize
your time some more
because I find you very interesting.
And I think actually many
of the things that you said
lead me into this next question,
this idea that creating your own spaces
is fundamental to activism.
And the idea that you
grow as activists I think
are fairly new-ish ideas for many of us.
I mean, some of you were
speaking about activism
from when you were younger.
I remember when I attempted
activism at the age of 10,
there were no options
for digital participation
or creating my own space in that same way.
So I'm wondering,
you've been on this
journey for a while now.
You have been activists
and leaders for some time.
And I'm wondering if in
the span of that time
you've noticed any differences in the way
that you've been able to engage
or the impact that your voice has made.
And I know you did a
little bit speak to this
but was there anything
specific that you've noticed
has changed since you started?
- So, I mean, for me at
least, being an activist
means reacting to the
times you're living in
and changing times being present.
And I constantly change my
ways and try to highlight
new issues when it happens
something in our world
that didn't happen a week ago that is new.
Because we know that what
happens in the world around us,
in society, in one way
or another happens to us.
So the COVID pandemic is one
example where I needed to like
change my activism in
order to reach people.
We created campaigns digitally
and movements digitally
instead to reach people.
And at least in my part of the
world and the war in Ukraine
has changed what I talk about
when I talk about activism,
when I talk about climate advocacy.
And we talk about the
connections between war and peace
and democracy and climate change
and nature changes more often now.
And we talk about fossil fuel dependency,
how it's important that we move away
from fossil fuel dependency
in order to create peace,
to not be reliant on dictatorships.
So that's just examples of
things that are happening
in recent years that has
kind of changed the way
I do activism and what
that highlights in my work.
- Thank you, Penelope.
That was a great example of practically
what that looks like for you.
And I appreciate you sharing that.
Kyle, I think I noticed
you pop up earlier.
Did you have something you wanted to add?
- The thing that's always difficult for me
'cause I'm a bit of a luddite,
is I have to like keep up on
which social media platforms
and like how best to
communicate with the people
I'm trying to reach.
Because like a lot of the
times when I'll be working
with UNICEF or the IOCDF, they'll be like,
just like, let's post
something to like forbes.com
and let's engage youth there.
And I'll have to be like, no,
that's not what we're using.
Like let's start a TikTok right now
and see if we can reach people that way.
So that's something I always
have to keep up on and change.
- Thank you.
I'm not sure if our other speakers
had anything they wanted to add.
- Yeah, I would just
like to add something.
I think for me personally,
I've learned more about my audience
and the changes that they experience.
I think especially in the Caribbean,
the leadership has always
been traditionally top down
with youth participation may not be always
meaningful or long term.
And I think along with
that I've realized that
as activists and advocates,
we can only reach so much due
to this huge knowledge gap.
And this made me really
realize the importance
for education and encouragement,
understanding how we are uniquely affected
and how we are contributors yet victims.
And I think really
understanding that has played
a major role in how
I've tweaked my activism
as Penelope was saying,
adjusted my own advocacy
to reach my audience and young people here
understanding how we're
affected by natural disasters,
flooding, and what we can do
in order to mitigate and adapt.
- Thank you, Priyanka.
And I think your answers have
also helped conceptualize
what exactly activism can
look like across the board
which is great.
I am conscious of the time,
so I think I'd like to take
one question from the audience
before passing over to
Kyle Pruett to close.
So we have a question from
Paul Stevenson which is,
what guidance or experiences
do the panel have
for strategies that help
to sustain their movements
or spaces?
And Paul clarifies that this
could include sustaining
momentum and motivation as
much as funding and resourcing.
- I can take over.
So you said it really well Paul there,
funding is really vital for our movements.
And moreover, funding that
doesn't alter the movement
because sometimes we're
conditioned to the ideas
that we can present in our
movements to the funding.
And again, what I would say
again in the momentum part
would be children and youth advocates
need to understand that they're
making a difference, right?
So trying to engage them
in very meaningful ways
and seeing how they make that impact
is going to keep momentum up.
Also mentorship, I know
that it's very important
and I talked about it
in my speech as well,
to have somebody who has been
through different experiences
and can mentor the movement
without diminishing
the light of each person
who is part of the movement.
And I would also say that
it's important to be mindful
of the mental health of
children and of youth advocates.
I know that I was ready to
do absolutely everything
for the movement and that
meant a lot of burnout
and not having the tools
to navigate spaces.
And so I would see a lot
of children being pushed
to their limits by activism and by adults
who didn't really know how
to approach this, right?
So make sure that when
you're engaging children
and to keep this momentum up,
you give them the space to also rest,
to also play, to also enjoy childhood.
So that's from my part.
- Thank you, Dominique.
Would any of the other
panelists like to add to that?
No, fantastic.
In which case Kyle Pruett,
I will hand it over to you.
Thank you very much everyone.
- Thank you, Aditi.
I am sorry to say this
wonderful conversation
which in my view is just
beginning has to come to close
because we've run out of time.
A few final thoughts, one
about the concept of resilience
which Dominique and
others have talked about.
In my own view as a child psychiatrist,
I have seen resilience massively misused.
It is not an individual trait of a child.
In fact, that can be so politicized
that if it is an individual trait
then why should governments do anything
to help children who are vulnerable?
Resilience is a property
of an environment,
not just simply the child that's in it,
but the state around it,
the people that love that
child and protect it as well.
So let's not be simple-minded when we come
to talk about resilience.
And our panel obviously is way ahead
of many of us in understanding that.
I would like to conclude our
comments with an invitation
to think together about
how ECPC could use such a
youth working group to move forward.
Their passion, their
competence, and their ability
to really provoke us to
talk about the right things
makes perfect sense.
Follow us on the ECPC newsletter.
The third lecture in
this series will feature
Sherrie Westin who is the
President of Sesame Workshop
and Dr. Hiro Yoshikawa
who will be talking about
a variety of interventions that have been
phenomenally successful in migratory
and refugee camps around the world.
Thank you for being with us.
Thank you to the panel.
What a contribution they
have made to us today.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)